[Music]
my name is Martha white I'm an assistant
professor at the University of Alberta
and computing science department and
also the director of RLE I I work in an
area called reinforcement learning and
it's about having an agent interact with
the world the real world around it in a
trial-and-error way and the higher level
goal is about having an agent learning
in a continual way you want you don't
just want to have an ego that you
programmed offline that you're deploying
to the real world we kind of think of
them like agents like we are they are
constantly learning as they're
interacting with the world so the
potential of applications is really big
I would argue that anywhere where humans
are currently doing intelligent things
or that we have intelligent systems is a
great place for reinforcement learning
when you have this agent and it's
continually interacting in the world it
needs to actually take in that flow of
data and summarize it into some compact
form that lets it reason about the world
so you can't just remember everything
it's seen you an imagined it has to pick
out the most important things and store
that information and unconstant Lee
update what it currently believes about
the world so research in general is it's
always been important but I would argue
it's becoming even more and more
important as you're entering this age
where information is just a huge economy
you know expertise is extremely
important if from an industry
perspective I think investing in
research is great because we help
develop that industry but we also
attract really good people to Canada who
will then produce good students that
will start those companies or they
themselves will decide to help start
those companies and that's in fact
exactly what's happened in Edmonton
you